okay yesterday I told you that there
have been countless Russians caught on
tape on video
stuffing multiple ballots at ballot
boxes in Vladimir Putin's recent quote
massive re-election win with quote
seventy seven percent of the vote and we
showed you a bunch of those different
videos on yesterday's program just an
incredible win as it's been reported
seventy seven percent for Putin is a
record high in any Russian presidential
election in history except for the fact
that dozens and dozens of people are on
camera just stuffing piles of ballots in
the ballot boxes so the White House was
asked about this and the apoplexy with
which press secretary Sarah Huckabee
Sanders was so obviously staying away
from any actual criticism or even
acknowledgement of the undeniable
reality that this re-election was a
total sham scam and again that doesn't
mean Putin would have lost but I don't
think anybody who is a clear and clear
thinking rational individual believes
that Vladimir Putin got 77% of the vote
with 67 percent turnout press secretary
Sarah Huckabee Sanders asked about this
and it is just absolutely fantastic take
a listen I'm sorry does the White House
believe that the election in Russia was
free and fair in terms of the election
there were focused on our elections we
don't get to dictate how other countries
operate what we do know is that Putin
has been elected in their country and
that's not something that we can dictate
to them how they operate we can only
focus on the freeness and the fairness
of our elections something we 100% fully
support and something we're going to
continue to do everything we can to
protect to make sure bad actors don't
have the opportunity to impact them in
any way yeah except you're not even
doing that you're not even doing what
you can do to prevent other actors from
impacting our elections but the remember
the question was was the Russian
election free and fair and the answer
was we don't control other countries
elections our focus
is our elections and we can't tell
Russia what to do waitwhat health she
answered a question that wasn't actually
asked and reporters need to get together
and hold her accountable
Sarah Huckabee Sanders that's an answer
but it's an answer to a question that
was never asked what about answering the
question we did ask which is what is the
belief of the white house what is the
position of the White House and of the
president with regard to the fairness of
the election that took place if the
question had been does the White House
believe that the United States should
interfere in Russian elections oh well
okay she answered and she says no no the
United States shouldn't interfere in
Russian elections but that was never the
question and in another clip it's just
another example of the same thing
Republican Senator John McCain
accurately called the recent 77%
reelection of Russian President Vladimir
Putin a sham election what does the
White House think about what John McCain
said here is Sarah Huckabee Sanders once
again disagree with Senator McCain's
characterization of this as a sham
election we disagree with the fact that
we shouldn't have conversations with
Russia there are important topics that
we should be able to discuss and that is
why the president is going to continue
to have that dialogue at the same time
we've been very clear in the actions
that we've taken that we're going to be
tough on Russia particularly when it
comes to areas that we feel where
they've stepped out of place we what do
you think about McCain calling it a sham
election anybody who says we shouldn't
talk to Russia is wrong but what nope
nobody asked about that nobody asked you
about talking to Russia the question is
Senator McCain called it a sham and we
want to know what the White House thinks
about that if the question had been does
the White House believe we shouldn't be
talking to Russia then the answer given
by Sarah Huckabee Sanders might have
made even like a tiny bit of sense now
here is where it gets really really good
and that has to do with Donald Trump's
response to this election of
pootin compared to not only what the
White House claimed was going to be
Donald Trump's response but also
compared to what Donald Trump was
advised to do in response to the
so-called election of Vladimir Putin and
that's what I want to talk about next
today's program is sponsored in part by
blinka the entire idea behind blinka
stand the service they provide is
perfect for me
and I assume really great for a lot of
people in our audience too if you watch
this show you know I read a lot of
nonfiction books and blink astiz an app
that takes nonfiction books and it
distills the most important points and
insights from the book down to a
powerful package of information which
can be read or listened to in about 15
minutes on your mobile device or tablet
you can zip through books really quickly
I still think it's great to absorb the
wisdom of books by reading them slowly
and in their entirety deep reading is
what it's called but not everybody I
know I don't have the time to read all
the non-fiction books that I really want
to so for the ones I can't read blink
astiz the next best thing
huge selection for one low flat rate you
get access to thousands of books you can
switch between text and audio both
online and offline and you also get
personalized recommendations based on
books you've already chosen join over 4
million people already using bling cos
that made the iTunes best apps of 2017
list it's free to try but you can also
get a 20% discount on a yearly
membership by visiting blinkers comm
slash Pakman if you're watching on
youtube we've put a link in the
description underneath the video again
that's blinking comm /p a que ma N